bonjour aujourd'hui nous sommes sur bwin
house un jus doré avec des clowns c'est
parti alors plaît j'ai tout compris mais
je ne vous dirai pas parce que je suis
un connard non en vrai j'ai juste
compris la fin ils ont dit aux il se
lève va prévenir les autres et voilà
donc on se retrouve dans un super pièce
très coloré très joyeuse mais qui dit
pièce colorée joyeuse du clown et qui
dit cloud dit alors on y va
c'est parti ou alors you should take the
map take your map mme salamin de passer
carrément bien comme naples on a tous
des vieilles cartes trop moche et eux
ils ont les cabanes gauchy alors pour ce
guide est très pratique
alors get into the room marqué dans
norma m20 jaune jaune bleu m what
c'est ça qui se passe c'est complètement
watch out the maze will try to get you
lost the mais c'est parce que c'est ok
what you va te faire un toboggan de
10000 m ah c'est quoi ça pour rien
[ __ ] deuil
qu'est ce que tu as maté comme ça hein
qu'est ce que tu as tes lakhdar gmt live
qu'elle a eu deux arrêts dont il est le
fracking jo et dont elle est si la faut
que j'aille à gauche et encore gauche on
peut pas un madame x qu'à une armoire
ok c'est juste une voilà une armoire
mais c'est quoi ce jeu ouais
eh ben je m'assois et je tape la tête
contre le mur même plutôt oui incroyable
qu'on brûle ascione
après avoir complètement tchité en
appuyant sur l dans toutes les salles du
jeu du wind
waouh alors je suis maintenant qu'elles
disent allez fêtons ce apprenant des
bonbons j'adore le tapis qui fait le
tour du siège pour ta soir quel
architecte qui a inventé ça pourquoi le
tapis fait pas juste ça hop et tu
t'assois n'ont pas non mais parce qu'ils
forment un point d'interrogation je sais
que vous me regardez maudite souris les
toilettes sont pas des hommes ni des
femmes et des aliens
non mais quitte à éduquer quoi quitte à
éduquer sol en papier donc il ya des
clowns qui vont poursuivre ok alors il
faut lose you when you don't look est ce
que c'était la mort la plus rapide qu'on
ait jamais vu sur ce jeu mais fait
clairement pas là il y en a une à cette
espèce de qui volaille qui nous
regardent en arguant regarder le 3e set
après l'iris moi je te taire previrisq
coup de tête on voit vous donnerai du
clown coucou hockey à voile et la maman
maman maman nextmap et demain ma carte
est décédé c'était des densités des
bonbons enfin le triplé cette action
c'était des dents ouais c'était des
dents tout à fait alors c'est parti
ok ok wasquehal mais arrête ça suffit
home est commentée éduquer d'accord
enfin thomas hawk et voilà d'accord bon
ok ok je te fais plus
bénac mais j'ai même pas commencé à
jouer what the bear un [ __ ] [ __ ] je
vais te défoncer quoi quoi qu'est ce
qu'il ya toi c'est ta coupe de cheveux
la quitteront comme ça non alors
pourquoi tu fais ça pour quoi
un arrête arrête tu arrêtes regardez moi
là ce petit con là hein quoi ta tête tu
vois pas qu'est un problème non 1 1 2 3
soleil 1 2 3 soleil 1 2 3 soleil un
grand soleil je te vois qu aucun c'est
bon c'est cette salle
au look oui d'accord très bien non
pardon non ne me tuez pas enfin enfin
aux affaires en ardèche oméga bien
c'était mon imitation du manège voit
bien ceux qui devant ce merveilleux oeil
parce que cette pièce est complètement
buggé
quand tu regardes les yeux des fois et
bien les tapis ça va être quand même à
rouler d'un coup d'une sais pas pourquoi
bref on se quitte sur un pur gros vers
de multiples prix à bientôt
biz est ce que tu aimes les décors
magiques qui volent et qui font des
craintes arcanciane et bien vous le dire
j'ai jamais vu de lui
oh [ __ ] qu'est ce qu'elles sont belles
on peut le nom squeeze alors vous